[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier bei Bild das
ist das immer weiter so in diesem Krieg
das so sehr verzweifeln lässt das
Vernichten das Töten immer weiter die
Frontlinie mal ein paar Kilometer in die
eine Richtung mal in die andere immer
weiter es bricht jetzt das zweite
Kriegsjahr an in diesem zermürbenden
Krieg und diese Frage ist offen was ist
eigentlich unser Plan in diesem Krieg
darüber diskutieren wir mit diesen
Gästen mit Markus Merkel Fahrrad DDR
Bürgerrechtler fast 20 Jahre
Bundestagsabgeordneter für die SPD er
hat den Wehrdienst verweigert damals
noch in der NVA und ist jetzt auch für
die Waffenlieferung julian
niederkrümelin ist bei uns Philosoph wer
war Gerhard Schröders
Kulturstaatsminister jetzt ist er viel
zu Chef des deutschen etharz
mehr als 40 Jahre bei den Grünen bis
2017 Chef der Heinrich böllstiftung und
danach dann Chef und Gründer der denkt
Fabrik Zentrum liberale moderne Bischof
Christoph Christian
die Kirche Berlin Brandenburg in Bischof
der sich gerne auch politisch zu Wort
meldet einmischt in diesem Fall derzeit
auch für deutsche Panzerlieferungen
herzlich willkommen ihnen allen hierbei
Bild herr Fuchs auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
komme ich immer in einer Hauswand vorbei
und auf diese Hauswand ist gesprüht es
ist nicht unser Krieg und dann sehen Sie
hier auf das Bild
wütend fast ein dickes doch dieses Bild
finde ich bildet so viel ab nach einem
Jahr Krieg
was würden Sie sagen ist das unser Krieg
ich würde sagen es ist unser Krieg ob
wir es wollen oder nicht
weil Putin nicht nur der Ukraine sondern
auch dem Westen den Krieg erklärt hat
und weil dieser Krieg nicht darauf
abzielt die Ukraine zu unterwerfen
oder zumindest ein großes Stück aus der
Ukraine herauszubrechen
sondern es ist auch eine Attacke auf die
europäische Friedensordnung der Attacke
auf das Völkerrecht ist eine Attacke und
auf die Grundwerte auf den Europa
aufbaut und auch auf unsere künftige
Sicherheit wenn Putin mit diesem Krieg
durchkommt wird es nicht der letzte sein
sondern dann wird der nächste
wahrscheinlich auf nahtoderatorium
ausgetragen werden in ihrer Familie auch
unser Krieg
also es ist auf jeden Fall ein Krieg der
die ganze Weltbevölkerung betrifft wir
haben Veränderungen in den ökonomischen
Beziehungen wir haben ein Zunahme von
Armut und Elend im globalen Süden auch
wegen der gestiegenen
Nahrungsmittelpreise deswegen gibt es
auch eine allgemeines Weltinteresse das
dieser Krieg möglichst rasch zum Ende
kommt und er ist insofern unser Krieg
als er auf europäischen Boden
stattfindet und wir die Hoffnung hatten
nach dem Ende des Kalten Krieges dass
wir eine stabile Friedensordnung
entwickeln bei der so etwas nicht mehr
möglich ist aber derjenige der das daran
gesprüht hat an die Hauswand der Merkel
der Markt im Sinn gehabt haben nicht zu
erklären warum dieser Krieg unser Leben
beeinflusst sondern er wollte den
Statement sagen und sagt wir wollen uns
oder wir sollen uns da raushalten und
dann ist das übersprüht worden und mit
dem gegenteiligen Statement nee das ist
eben doch unser Krieg das zeigt im
Moment die Zerrissenheit auch hier in
Deutschland
wir haben ein ethisches Dilemma das muss
man ganz klar sagen bei Milosevic
wurde wie Kriegspartei als Milosevic die
Kosovaren
vertrieben hat mit Morden Anfang anfing
und da haben wir eingegriffen und das
war richtig so hier haben wir auch ein
Klick Putins dann ein Überfall auf ein
Opfer das keinerlei anders dazu gegeben
hat außer dass es auf seiner eigenen
Lebensart
europäisch zu sein frei zu sein zu
wollen und einen demokratischen Weg
gehen zu wollen darauf behaart hat
und dieser Überfall insofern
müssten wir eigentlich ethisch
so handeln wie wärmelocevic wir können
es nicht weil Russland Atom macht ist da
gibt es eine Grenze weil das nun
wirklich dann eine Linie ist die wir
nicht überschreiten dürft deshalb denke
ich müssen wir alles dafür tun um die
Ukraine zu unterstützen dass sie sich
wehren kann wir müssen Perspektiven neu
Bedenken auch für die Ukraine auch für
diese Lebensart was da heißt das
Demokratie und dergleichen insofern ist
es wirklich auch unser Krieg denn wir
sind mit gemeint unter stimme ich halt
fix zu weil klar ist Demokratie und all
diese unsere Werte die internationale
Ordnung werden angegriffen und hier ist
es so wichtig dass wir geschlossen
stehen unser Krieg oder nicht unser
Krieg bisher versteht bleiben wie nehmen
sie im Moment die Bevölkerung hier in
Deutschland war wie zerrissen wie
gespalten wie polarisiert die
Gesellschaft auch ihre Gemeinde also so
polarisiert wie das jetzt klingt sind
wir glaube ich nicht sondern in der Tat
nehme ich war das eine große Zahl von
Menschen gerade auch in den Kirchen
sagen als erstes sind die Menschen die
zu uns kommen die die uns angehen die
geflüchteten in ganz vielen christlichen
evangelischen kirchlichen Gemeinden sind
Menschen untergekommen und natürlich
geht uns das an wenn eine Nachbar
überfallen natürlich ganz genau so in
den Schulen in den Kitas vielen
Gemeinden Stelle gefunden so ist es und
das geht uns an und genauso geht uns an
dass die Freiheit des ukrainischen
Volkes die Freiheit der Menschen die
hier einfach überfallen worden sind
immer auch eine Frage nach unserer
Freiheit in diesem Europa ist so wir
Füchs am Anfang gesagt hat wenn Putin
mit diesem Krieg durchkommt dann wird
sich die Weltordnung in der Tat auch in
Europa völlig verändert die sagen gerade
so gespalten so polarisiert ist das Land
gar nicht nehmen das ein bisschen anders
war in diesen Tagen und dann im
Wochenende ist eine sehr große
Demonstration angesagt hier in Berlin
Schweiz zwei mehrere Demonstration
ohnehin im ganzen Land aber eine
möglicherweise besonders große Alice
Mutter und Sahra Wagenknecht haben sie
mit initiiert und gehen auf die Straße
in niedere Rumänien haben sie verstanden
wofür eigentlich also ich bin in
Cambridge
in dieser Woche und werde da mein neues
Buch vorstellen Siri auf practical
riesen das passt vielleicht hier zum
Thema sie werden da auf keinen Fall sein
bei der Demonstration die fragt sie aber
nicht weil sie mit verhaften wollte für
diese Demonstration sondern haben sie
verstanden wofür die auf die Straße
gehen ja also den den Text den man liest
ist er ziemlich eindeutig äh der Text
jedenfalls was immer man vielleicht noch
an politischen Motiven da vermuten mag
ich meine alle schwarze und wagenknechte
mir nicht dieselbe politische Auffassung
und es gibt ja noch ein paar andere mit
Initiatoren offensichtlich wie z.B der
frühere
vizekommissions-eugen und so weiter
Case Mann von der evangelischen Seite
und so also wenn man den Text liest dann
geht es darum dass es zu einem möglichst
baldigen Friedensschluss aufgerufen wird
zugleichen Zeit auch der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg Putins
verurteilt wird
und unnötiges Blutvergießen wenn ich es
richtig in Erinnerung habe nicht weiter
stattfinden soll das ist eigentlich die
Botschaft worüber man sprechen muss und
dass Instagram solchen Aufruf natürlich
nicht enthalten wie sollen eigentlich
die nächsten Schritte sein wie stellt
ihr euch das genau vor vielleicht
sprechen wir ja das ist der
Sendungstitel wenn Herr niederlass
gerade ihrem Eindruck nachgehen diese
zwei und die Masse die dort erwartet
wird am Wochenende für den Frieden auf
die Straße oder eher für den kremme
faktisch würde ich sagen der greifen sie
Partei für den Kreml wenn sie fordern
die Einstellung der Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine das ist der Dreh und
Angelpunkt man kann unterschiedlicher
Auffassungen darüber sein ob ein
Waffenstillstand jetzt die richtige
Forderung ist die Ukraine lehnen das ab
ich verstehe sehr gut warum dass sie
keinen eingefrorenen Konflikt haben
wollen bei dem
weite Teile ihres Territoriums und der
russische Vorherschaft kommen mit dem
entsprechenden Terrorregime was damit
verbunden ist das ja nicht ein Ende der
Gewalt so oder ob dieser Krieg
von der Ukraine letztlich gewonnen
werden muss und wir Sie möglichst
unterstützen müssen aber ihr die Waffen
zu verweigern
das bedeutet dass man faktisch Partei
für den Aggressor ergreift ja wenn man
eine verhandlungsfrieden will dann muss
man die Ukraine möglichst stark machen
weil die russische Führung erst bereit
sein wird die territoriale Integrität
und politisch Souveränität der Ukraine
anzuerkennen wenn sie am Rande einer
Niederlage steht vorher wird Putin seine
Kriegsziele nicht aufgeben jetzt da Herr
Merkel ihrem Eindruck nach um Frieden
oder geht es auch um die Frage auch bei
den vielen die da mitlaufen werden lass
uns alleine lass uns in Ruhe mit dem
ganzen Kram ihr könnt das Sterben
Hauptsache wir haben unseren Wohlstand
also ich kann nicht ausschließen dass
solche Leute mitlaufen bei den beiden
Autorinnen glaube ich das nicht und
trotzdem glaube ich dass es dich zu Ende
gedacht ist denn was heißt dann also
einmal stimme ich dem Sud dass wir
natürlich unterstützen müssen und er
sage ich mit allem was militärisch nötig
ist damit die Ukraine sich verteidigen
kann das ist mein erster Satz in der
zweite ist
dann wenn man nach Verhandlungen ruft
dann ist das allererste Jahr dass man
diesen Brief eigentlich an Putin
schicken muss und dann wenn er bereit
ist zu wahre beziehungsweise
zurückzuziehen
dann muss man gucken wie kann man das
stabilisieren oder man muss werden über
den Kopf von der Ukraine hinweg wird man
nicht verhandeln können
insofern ist das dann zu allererst eine
Frage an die Ukraine und auch das ist
eben schon gesagt worden ein
terrorialverlust und wir alle ich habe
noch keinen Start jetzt gefunden der
jetzt sagt
der Verlust der Krim was wir alle nicht
anerkannt haben oder in der Ostukraine
all diese Gebiete würden jetzt nicht
mehr zu Ukraine gehören wollen wir etwa
sagen wir sollen und dann da wohnen
Menschen und wir haben es ein Butcher
und an vielen Orten erlebt was dort
passiert wenn Russen dort die Herrschaft
haben und von daher kann das in meinen
Augen kein Rat sein anhand dieser Lenski
sozusagen die sind dann nicht mehr egal
und von daher sage ich ja von daher es
ist nicht zu Ende gedacht glaube was
sagen sie zu dem zu diesem ja offenbaren
Zweckbündnis Wagenknecht schwarze was
halten Sie davon
also ich glaube dass da eine neue
politische Allianz sich herausbildet die
von ganz links
Wagenknecht Flügel der Linkspartei also
die alte anti-nato anti-amerikanische
Tradition bis ganz rechts
also bis zur sagen AFD und dazwischen
sind Leute die tatsächlich glauben dass
es nichts Wichtigeres gibt als dass die
Waffen heute Schweigen mit denen muss
man sich auseinandersetzen was bedeutet
eigentlich Frieden ja ist Frieden
einfach das Aufhören von Krieg oder
bedeutet Frieden auch ein Leben in
Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit für die
Ukraine ja und mit den Menschen die
pazifistischer Gesinnung sind die sagen
den Krieg furchtbar finden wir alle
jeder Krieg ist eine humanitäre
Katastrophe das ist doch gar keine Frage
und trotzdem gibt es notwendige Kriege
und es gibt gerechte Kriege und deshalb
muss man mit den Ringen während ich
glaube dass die beiden politischen
Flügel die das jetzt sagen vorantreiben
wir sind
nicht nur
Vertreter einer pro russischen Situation
die sind meines Erachtens auch eine
Gefahr für die liberale Demokratie nein
sowas egal sein wann hat Demonstration
Werder mitläuft dass man damit dann
nicht ja hat man trägt man dafür keine
Verantwortung oder muss man sich eben
doch schwarzer und Wagenknecht ab und zu
umdrehen wer da hinterher läuft ich
glaube man muss mindestens als
Veranstalter sehr klar positionieren und
dann auch abgrenzen man ist dann auch
von vor dem Beifall von der falschen
Seite nie ganz gefallen das ist klar
aber die klare Abgrenzung muss erfolgen
und die vermisse sich an dieser Stelle
auch trotzdem will ich an dieser Stelle
einmal auch für meine Kolleginnen Margot
kästnerstelle nein an dieser Stelle will
ich erstmal deutlich sagen auch sie geht
aus einer großen Frieden sucht an dieser
Stelle mit und wie Herr Fuchs gesagt hat
wir müssen dann darüber reden was
gerechter Frieden heißt und nur ein
gerechter Frieden hier drüber gespielt
ein Name der diesen Frieden verdient
habe ich bisher noch nicht will ich aber
unbedingt jetzt in dieser Woche noch
machen es ist ja nicht meine Position
aus der Herausforderung auf die Straße
gegangen wird das will ich klar sagen
aber ich will den Menschen jedenfalls
Margot Käßmann und vielen anderen auch
nicht die Sehnsucht nach Frieden
absprechen genau darüber muss diskutiert
werden wir haben das Leitbild vom
gerechten Frieden in der evangelischen
Friedensethik in den letzten Jahrzehnten
entwickelt und stehen jetzt an dieser
Stelle auch sozusagen vor einer
Situation in der das neue justiert und
neue präzise bestimmt werden muss weil
um jetzt mal eine andere auch sehr
bekannte evangelische Christen zu
zitieren weil auch vor geringer sagt nur
ein gerechter Frieden einer in Freiheit
kann dann auch Frieden genannt werden
insofern der Streit geht tief durch die
evangelische Kirche Gesellschaft durch
die Grüne Partei wenn gleich die ja gibt
es auch margottes man auch sicherlich
eher grün in jeder geht auch tief durch
die durch die SPD sie waren damals
Kulturstaatsminister als Gerhard
Schröder auch Nein zum Irakkrieg gesagt
hat sie ziehen viele Parallelen zu der
Zeit damals in ihren Aufsätzen damals
war ein Satz mit dem Gerhard Schröder
auch in den Wahlkämpfen die Herzen
zugeflogen ist Solidarität ja aber
Abenteuer nein ist dieser Satz heute
aktuell würden Sie sagen ja der ist
aktuell der ist immer aktuell die Frage
ist
zu entscheiden was geboten ist hängt den
hohem Maße davon ab was der Fall ist
welche Fakten wir anerkennen müssen und
da gibt's unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen ich bin zum Beispiel kein
Militärexperte ich kann das nur aus
zweiter Hand beurteilen diejenigen die
sagen es kann erst einen Frieden geben
wenn die Ukraine
gesiegt hat und zwar gesiegt im
umfassenden Sinne also Eroberung der
neueroberten Gebiete seit dem 24 Februar
letzten Jahres Eroberung der
Separatisten Gebiete im Osten wenn sie
doch Befreiung Befreiung ja lass uns mal
das jetzt mal offen weil wir nicht genau
wissen wie die Bevölkerung dazu russisch
oder Ukrainisch stehen oder eben
alle die ich gesprochen habe und die man
so seriös recherchieren kann ein
bisschen auf zum Oberbefehlshaber der
amerikanische Streitkräfte kommen in
seiner faktischen einzig das ist kein
ethische Stellungnahme zu der faktischen
Einstellung oder Einschätzung dass
dieser umfassende Sieg der Ukraine
militärisch nicht möglich ist man kann
vielleicht jetzt mal Vorsicht dick noch
was hinzufügen den kann militär-experte
vorsichtig hinzufügen wenn er mit sagen
wir mal einer Verzehnfachung der
westlichen Waffenlieferungen wie es ja
von der ukrainischen Seite gefordert
wurde
wenn es möglich wäre dann ist zu
vermuten dass spätestens bei der Frage
Krim
ist zu einer unkontrollierten Eskalation
dieses Konfliktes kommt das ist der
Punkt den Markus Meckel gerade
angesprochen hat weil diese nuklear
macht natürlich auch über taktische
Atomwaffen verfügt wenn sie dermaßen
stark in die Defensive kommt ist zu
befürchten sie setzt sie ein das ist
eine Fakten Frage die ich nicht wirklich
beurteilen kann mir fällt nur auf das
Militärexperten fast durchgängig vor
allem die Aktiven richtig fast
durchgängig dieser Auffassung sind jetzt
Moment wenn dem so ist wenn wir
tatsächlich zu erwarten haben dass hier
noch mal wenn es ein Jahr weitergeht ist
ein vor und zurückgeht mit vielleicht
noch mal
250.000 Toten auf beiden Seiten dann
muss man jetzt überlegen welche
Möglichkeiten gibt es diese Todesfälle
zu verhindern und trotzdem zu verhindern
da sind wir uns zum Beispiel völlig
einig hier am Tisch
das ist keinen diktatfrieden gibt das
Putin seine Kriegsziele nicht erreicht
deswegen machen wir keine Karikaturen
war ich der Meinung der Ukraine muss
geholfen werden auch mit Waffen geholfen
werden damit Putin seine Kriegsziele
nicht erreicht ich bin aber auch der
Meinung dass es unverantwortlich ist der
Illusion anzuhängen und einige an diesem
Tisch einmal politische Vergangenheit
die sehr stark mit Illusionen verbunden
waren zum Beispiel mauristischen
Illusionen sind sie gemeint ja höchsten
sie gemeint
ja diese Neigung sozusagen sich
Wunschbilder zu machen und dann danach
Politik zu machen ist hoch gefährlich
das vergisst man nicht das prägt
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen näher an den
ukrainischen Realität also jetzt mal
lassen mich kürzere reden wenn man jetzt
sagt wir müssen alles tun damit weder
die eine Seite noch die andere Seite
jetzt erwarten kann umfassend zu siegen
weil nur dass die Chance beinhaltet
einen Ende des der Waffen
Auseinandersetzung zu haben dann heißt
das noch keineswegs dass damit
entschieden ist was geschieht zum
Beispiel Rückzug Russlands vor die
Grenzen die es vorher also kontrolliert
hat vom 24 Februar das wäre ein
wichtiger Punkt zweitens warum redet
niemand darüber dass man vielleicht mal
die Bevölkerungen befragt wie die das
sehen und der Egide der Vereinten
Nationen auf der Krim oder in den beiden
Separatisten Gebiete im Osten warum rede
darüber niemand das haben wir im
Saarland so gemacht das war nicht der
schlechteste 55 entschieden
das muss absolut sauber sein ich meine
wir reden immer von Demokratie in der
internationalen Politik spielt auch mit
Demokratie general mehr
sie sind direkt angesprochen
Erniedrigung hat einmal kräftig
ausgeteilt und gesagt wir sitzen da
einer Illusion auch schon immer in ihrem
Leben das können wir noch einmal zur
Seite legen aber eben auch aktuell weil
sie an einen Sieg über die russische
Armee glauben will ist nicht eine Frage
des Glaubens ich bin zu wenig
Militärexperte wie Herrn
aber es ist keineswegs so dass die
Militärs dann eine einhellige Auffassung
hätten ich weiß gerade in der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz hat mir petrios
angehört habe mir general Holz angehört
es gibt eine Interview des generell des
generalinspektors der Bundeswehr der
sagt es ist durchaus möglich dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt
sehr weich und unendlich sind
möglicherweise auch Erich Fahrt den
früheren Berater von Angela Merkel der
auch gesagt hat höchstens eine Woche
dann hat die russische Armee gesucht das
waren die Experten die am Anfang sagten
in zwei Wochen ist die Ukraine
kollabiert und die russische Armee steht
man hat nicht nur den Widerstandsgeist
der Ukraine vollkommen unterschätzt
und dieser Widerstandskreis ist im Laufe
des Krieges noch gewachsen ja und das
sagen auch übrigens alle Umfragen in der
Ukraine und der Ausgang dieses Krieges
hängt ganz maßgeblich von uns ab von dem
Ausmaß an militärischer und finanzieller
Unterstützung dass der Westen bereit ist
der Ukraine zu geben das ist nicht
einfach eine naturwissenschaftliche
Frage wie dieser Krieg endet ja und es
kommt auch auf ganz klare Signale an die
russischen Machteliten an dass dieses
Land mit Putin keine Zukunft hat meine
russischen Freunde
die jetzt fast alle im Exil sind die zum
Teil im Straflager waren oder auch noch
heute sind sagen alle Russland muss
diesen Krieg verlieren weil das die
einzige Chance ist auf demokratischen
Wandel in Russland und auf einen
stabilen Frieden in Europa mit diesen
Regime wird es keine nachhaltigen
Frieden in Europa geben
es geht Putin nicht um ein paar
territoriale Gewinne sondern es geht ihm
darum die Ukraine als eigenständige
Nation die Eindruck zu zerstören und die
europäische sicherheitsordnung
umzusetzen Eindruck dass wir in diesen
12 Monaten Krieg diesem Ziel näher
gekommen sind dass die Ukraine diesem
Ziel näher gekommen ist
ja ich meine sie hat sich ja erfolgreich
verteidigt gegen die erste Welle der
russischen Angriffe sie hat Teile der
Territorien wieder zurückerobert die
Russland schon besetzt hatte
der Westen hat langsam ich würde immer
noch sagen zu langsam aber doch sich
aufgerafft die Ukraine entschiedener zu
unterstützen und zu sagen Moment wir
sind hier keine Zuschauer an der
Seitenlinie das ist auch unsere Sache in
der Ukraine wie weit man damit kommt
muss man sehen das ist in jedem Krieg so
niemand kann den Ausgang eines Krieges
mathematisch vorberechnen niemand aber
wir müssen alles tun um die Ukraine
möglichst stark zu machen auch mit Blick
auf mögliche Verhandlungen er mir Geld
es bleibt die entscheidende Frage glaubt
man daran dass man die russische Armee
besiegen oder zumindest entscheiden kann
um dann eben an den Verhandlungstisch
kehren zu können sitzen auch wieder
einer Illusion auf wie eine sagt oder
glauben sie fest daran ähm also ich kann
hier nur wiederholen dass ich das für
wichtig halte ich halte es für wichtig
dass wir alles tun damit dass wir alles
tun damit die Ukraine sich verteidigen
kann und ich finde ehrlich und ich sehe
jede Diskussion die wir ständig führen
über eine konkrete Waffenart
als hochproblematisch
hier sollten wir wie ich denke diese
Frage
dann den Militärs überlassen weil klar
ist dass wir in der Öffentlichkeit über
ein Leopard diskutieren dass wir über
die fragen brauchen wir jetzt den Panzer
oder denen oder können die nur in der in
der konkreten Gemengelage brauchen wie
ist es mit der Luftabwehr ich denke die
Frage der Luftabwehr ist zentral ich
denke auch dass wir dazu gehört übrigens
dann auch Flugzeuge all dies sage ich
was die Ukraine braucht und da bin ich
nicht entschuldige sie hier geht es um
was sie braucht um sich zu verteidigen
und das heißt auf dem Maß dessen was
völkerrechtlich wie vertreten auch das
Völkerrecht und wenn das eben doch eine
Grenze das finde ich
überhaupt nicht zur Debatte
muss man dann auch klar sagen es geht
nicht darum dass man alle Forderungen
erfüllt wenn sie falsch sind aber alles
was man militärisch braucht und das
heißt das muss man zuallererst mal
machen und insofern hängt wirklich von
uns als westlichen Ländern ungeheuer
viel ab und was ich mir wünsche oder
wünschte ist das nicht alles öffentlich
debattiert wird über jede Waffengattung
die dann sozusagen neues dass wir auch
als deutsche hier sozusagen vorne mit
einem stehen das muss nicht alles
öffentlich passieren aber es muss
moderierend sein damit wir möglichst als
Europa als der Westen der sich jetzt
gewissermaßen auch neu konstituiert auch
im transatlantischen Verhältnis dass wir
dieses stark machen und dieses gemeinsam
eintreten und dann kommen
wir zu schwer fällig zu langsam sind
oder weil es geheim bleiben also manches
muss geheim bleiben natürlich aber
glaube nicht dass die öffentlichen
Debatte und jeden Panzer das ist was zu
der Erkenntnis führt sondern ich glaube
dass die Solidarität sehr klar sein muss
dass man auch mit den Amerikanern und
das finde ich hat der Kanzler ja in
Bezug auf die die Leopard dann auch gut
gemacht wenn auch ein bisschen spät und
die Fragen stehen jetzt natürlich auch
an was tun wir und das gibt es dann
Grenzen und das ist für mich der Punkt
warum müssen wir erst anfangen
öffentlich festzustellen dass Munition
fehlt obwohl man schon weiß dass sie da
ist
solche Dinge denke ich sollten viel
schneller sehr operativ auch schon im
Vorhinein gemacht werden und dann geht
es um diese politischen Fragen ich finde
es ja zentral das Putin mit seiner an
die nato-politik den hat die erst
Feindbild aufbaut das ja schon da ein
Schiffbruch erhalten hat weil zwei
demokratische Länder Europas entschieden
haben dazu gehört die NATO zu stärken
aber die NATO wieder auch so zu stärken
dass sie nicht nur militärisch agiert
sondern die Zivil militärische
Zusammenarbeit die muss deutlich
verstärkt werden das sind wir oft
schwach da sind wir auch in früheren
Auseinandersetzungen schwach gewesen
hier müssen wir besser werden zwischen
EU und NATO zwischen Amerikanern und
NATO diese Frage der EU-Erweiterung das
Kandidaten statt das ist eine zentrale
Dimension die Zukunft Europas
entscheidet sich im Osten das müssen wir
begreifen und müssen wir durch
buchstabieren was das konkret heißt er
bis auf stehtlein Herr Mecke sagt gerade
nicht über jede Waffenart neu
diskutieren das ist nicht die Debatte
die uns vorantreibt sie haben sich
eingebracht in diese Debatte und haben
auch ganz offensiv für Waffenlieferung
plädiert im Zusammenhang mit der
Diskussion und Panzer Lieferung wie
erklären sie das innerhalb der Kirche
wie erklären sie das innerhalb der
Gemeinde und vor allen Dingen was ist
das Ziel für Sie von diesen
Panzerlieferungen also ich will mal das
Wort offensiv
ausmalen indem ich sage mit dem Hinweis
auf die große Zerrissenheit die das für
jeden Christen Menschen bedeuten muss
wenn ich für Waffenlieferungen eintrete
das ist ja nichts was wir so leicht hin
machen sondern was wir mit großen
Schmerzen machen und immer auch mit
Blick auf die friedensehnsucht die wir
zu verkündigen haben und die das erste
ist was aus der Bibel herausspricht ja
ja
interessant ist gibt es für sie als
geistlichen gute Waffen schlechte Waffen
nein es gibt nicht ein guter oder
schlechte Waffen es gibt Waffen die
Menschen Moment brauchen um sich und ihr
Land vor einem völkerrechtswidrigen
schrecklichen brutalen Angriff zu
verteidigen und darum geht auch an
dieser Stelle auf der einen Seite Waffen
gesegnet werden auf der ukrainischen
Seite auf der anderen Seite auf der
russischen Seite im mindestens ganz
genauso von den Kreml anhängenden
geistlichen dort wachsen gesegnet werden
Soldaten gesegnet werden überhaupt keine
Waffen kann es an dieser Stelle nicht
gehen und darf es auch nicht bin in sehr
dankbar dass sie dann noch mal
geht auch bei dem Werben darum dass ich
ein Verständnis für diese Position der
Regierung unseres Landes an der Stelle
haben niemals darum dass ich jetzt
offensiv mit einem hurra in diesen Krieg
möchte das ist uns alles total fern
sondern es geht in dieser schrecklichen
Situation als erstes darum und das ist
dann auch meine theologische und
christliche Begründung Menschen die
angegriffen werden beizuschauen und so
wie ich als Christ gerade auch in der
Ethik des ich muss Unrecht erleiden für
mich sprechen kann so darf ich eben
niemals das für andere verordnen ich
kann nicht dem anderen sagen du musst
das Unrecht einfach hinnehmen und darfst
dich nicht verteidigen und genau darum
geht es bei dieser Frage in einer
Situation die für uns alle schrecklich
ist zu sagen dann müssen auch Waffen
möglich sein und dann haben wir ja am
Anfang des Krieges diese Unterscheidung
zwischen den verteidigungs- und den
Angriffswaffen gehabt jetzt wird immer
deutlicher dass ich sozusagen diese
Trennlinie nicht scharf ziehen kann wenn
ich die Ukrainer nicht ihrem Schicksal
des angegriffen Seins einfach überlassen
will aber ich muss immer in dieser
theologisch christlichen ethisch klaren
Positionierung bleiben und darf nicht in
einen triumphahlen ihre Antwort zeigt
die Zerrissenheit und zeigt auch dass es
sie natürlich auch fühlt als geistiger
als jemand der vor der Gemeinde steht
das auch erklärt und mit sich bringt das
spürt man in dieser an dieser Antwort
und letztlich haben all diese Waffen die
solidarisch ein solidarisches Zeichen
setzen die zu Verteidigung dienen sollen
einziehen auch natürlich das ist völlig
klar in dieser schrecklichen Situation
gibt es eben keine Alternative aber das
möchte ich dann in dieser Runde auch
einmal sagen natürlich muss unsere
Anstrengung und das hört man ja hier
auch bei allen Beteiligten wieder dahin
gehen zu gucken welche Lösung gibt es
denn dann am Ende jedenfalls
meine ich jetzt nicht explizit nur die
deutsche die kleine Kirche sondern die
großen die katholische Kirche die große
protestantische Kirche zu wenig ein nein
das glaube ich nicht wir hatten ja auch
den die ökumenische Konferenz in
Karlsruhe im letzten Jahr große
Auseinandersetzung ich glaube wir sind
da zum Beispiel nach Moskau weil ich
glaube zunächst einmal sind wir auch in
der Pflicht auf die orthodoxe russische
Kirche einzuwirken dass sie endlich
aufhört diesen Krieg diesen Krieg Putin
zu unterhalten sich daran glauben Sie
daran putin ist ganz eng mit dem Bösen
weiblichen glauben Sie ernsthaft darin
wäre es eine Möglichkeit dass der Papst
nach Moskau fährt also diese Möglichkeit
will ich nicht ausschließen aber ich
glaube im Moment geht's ja noch nicht um
solche Zeichenhandlung die müssen auch
im richtigen Moment Erfolgen im Moment
geht es darum dass wir auch in der
großen Christengemeinschaft in der
Ökumene und gegenseitig so stärken dass
etwa die Position Kyrills als das
geächtet wird was sie ist eine
kriegstreibende Position die wir aus
christlicher Perspektive ganz klar
ablehnen so wie es in Herrn Stäblein
arbeitet und in der Kirche arbeitet zu
Mark ist auch in ihnen gearbeitet haben
in den vergangenen Monaten und immer
noch arbeiten sie haben eins den
Kriegsdienst verweigert das habe ich
gesagt auch in der DDR-Zeit damals bei
der nationalen Volks Ami was hat das
zwar noch ein bisschen anders als in
Wehrdienst im Westen zu verweigern was
hat das für sie damals bedeutet das war
sehr klares Bekenntnis damals für mich
durchaus auch pazifistisch also ich habe
geglaubt dass man als Christ keine Waffe
in die Hand nehmen muss sie haben
Nachteile dadurch
hätte weil ich hatte auch total
verweigert habe dann zwei Jahre
Gefängnis drauf das heißt das hätte
passieren können ist dann nicht passiert
das konnte man aber vorher natürlich
nicht wissen aber für mich waren auch
diese Begründung ich habe die später
wieder gefunden in den einzelnen Punkten
dass ich sage einerseits war es ein
partyistisches dann gab es auch
Deutschland ist zweimal ein Krieg
begonnen hat darf es dich tun und das
dritte war dass die beiden deutschen
Staaten meine gesamte Familie lebt im
Westen und ich sagte wir richten dich
die Waffen gegen aufeinander und ich
habe mal ab dann ja später
im Bundestag die Auslandseinsätze
befürwortet weil ich der festen
Überzeugung bin dass so wie es Polizei
im innerstaatlichen gibt die natürlich
auch Gewalt anwenden muss gegen
Verbrecher dass dies auch international
geht aber es geht immer um die Stützung
und die Förderung und die Etablierung
des Rechts sie haben und das ist dann
auch die Aufgabe natürlich immer sehr
begrenzt aber wohl notwendig dann eben
auch wirklich mit voller Unterstützung
Teil dieser Erklärung damals ihrer
Begründung zur Kriegsdienstverweigerung
auch veröffentlicht transparent gemacht
sie haben damals geschrieben so sagen
sie ich möchte damit einen
Friedensdienst leisten der mir als der
man sich mögliche und für mich gangbare
erscheint es muss Menschen geben die
anfangen deutlich zu machen dass in der
Zukunft ein Weg der Gewaltlosigkeit und
der Liebe zum Mitmenschen eingeschlagen
werden muss haben sie diesen Glauben
zumindest in jedem Fall diesen Glauben
an die Gewaltlosigkeit verloren
also ich habe glaube nicht dass dies in
jeder Situation gilt das gilt übrigens
auch wir hatten jetzt gerade oder wir
haben dann die friedliche Revolution die
ja oft dann als Argument benutzt wird
übrigens auch innerhalb der Kirche wie
ich weiß als Argument benutzt wird etwa
von dem friedensbeauftragten wo ich
anderer Meinung bin wo ich sage dies ist
kein Modell
wir brauchen
Gewalt um Recht zu halten um da wo ein
Gewalttäter es bricht und dann eben
nicht nur also einer den Opfern
beizustehen aber auch das Rechte zu
erhalten und das ist eine ganz zentrale
Dimension zu der ich mich bekenne und
insofern habe ich natürlich auch einen
Weg der Veränderung bin ich gegangen
auch sie haben den Kriegsdienst
verweigert über eine andere
Vergangenheit die hat ja nie darüber den
gerade schon angesprochen mit
Kommunisten eine kommunistisches
Gedankengut sie haben sich sehr weit
verändert herr Fuchs wir haben heute
eben das haben wir in dieser Verbindung
auch gehört massiv eben für weitere
Waffenlieferungen warum
für mich war der Bosnienkrieg
sein ein politischer Wendepunkt dass ich
kommt tatsächlich aus einer
antibilitaristischen sagen Tradition die
würde ich für mich auch weiter
reklamieren übrigens auch das Prinzip
Gewaltfreiheit in
innergesellschaftlichen
Auseinandersetzung ja ich bin ein
absoluter Befürworter des des
Gewaltverzichts als Mittel der
politischen Auseinandersetzung
Gewaltfreiheit ist ein ein hohes Gut was
Zivilität in einer politischen
Auseinandersetzung erst
gewährleistet aber wir mussten erleben
übrigens nicht erst in der 90er Jahren
ich meine Deutschland das Deutsche Reich
musste in einem
furchtbaren Krieg niedergerungen werden
Europa und auch Deutschland ist
militärisch befreit worden dass dann
eine Lektion die man nicht einfach
vergessen kann ja und nie wieder kriegt
das bedeutet nie wieder Angriffskrieg
von deutschen Boden aus es gibt aber
noch das zweite nie wieder Völkermord
und das war Bosnien ja das Anfang der
90er Jahren Europa ein Krieg begonnen
wurde bis dahin waren sie ihre
Begründung Folgen zu naiv ja ich würde
sagen habe glaube ich unterschätzt diese
Rückkehr der Gewalt als Mittel der
Politik und um es mal theologisch zu
formulieren die Rückkehr des Bösen in
die Politik es gibt
Mächte des Bösen den man nur mit
Entschiedenheit begegnen kann würden Sie
heute noch den werdenden verweigern vor
diesem Hintergrund nein sie würden zum
Bund gehen
sehr hypothetisch aber würden sie noch
nicht
auch in der demokratische Armee dem
stimme ich zu wobei ich politisch heute
für eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht bin
das heißt mit der Wahlfreiheit für in
verschiedene Bereiche zu gehen um das
geweint wohl zu stärken und das halte
ich für zentral dass wir diese Weg gehen
zur Waffe greifen sie würden unser Land
verteidigen
ich würde in einer spezifischen
Situation ich würde Ihnen auch sagen
wenn ich jünger wäre auch ich würde in
die Ukraine gehen sie würden ihre Kinder
ihre Enkelkinder dorthin schicken nein
ich würde niemanden schicken ich habe
gesagt ich würde gehen weil ich das
Gefühl habe dass das ein ganz
entscheidender Auseinandersetzung für
die Zukunft Europas ist in niederrümelin
sie haben ja vor allen Dingen über die
Jüngeren gesprochen haben gesagt viele
die früher ganz stark eine Generation
die ganz stark für den Frieden war ganz
stark passivistisch unterwegs war die
sei mittlerweile eher hart belizistisch
geprägt wie die praktisch also
kriegsverherrlichend auch hat sich eine
solche Kriegsverherrlichung ihrer
Meinung breit gemacht ja also
Kriegsverherrlichung
wie bezeichnen wir das ja die einen sind
der Meinung wir müssen alles tun damit
möglichst bald ein Waffenstillstand oder
Friedensverhandlungen aufgenommen werden
übrigens Kollege hat das vor Weihnachten
gefordert er hat nicht in
Waffenstillstand gefordert aber
gefordert eine internationale Konferenz
einzuberufen die auslotet welche
friedenschancen ist gibt also damit man
der Legende dass die Ukraine
grundsätzlich immer schon gegen jede
Form von Friedensverhandlungen hat ja
auch im Gegenteil sie hat verhandelt da
gibt's sehr berühmte Beispiele die ein
bisschen umstritten sind in der
Interpretation
also lass mal diese Begriffe beiseite
aber es gibt eine auffälligen Schnitt
gewissermaßen in der Bevölkerung das ist
schon
erklärungs bitte dürftig dass eine
Generation von Kriegsdienst verweigeren
sage ich jetzt mal auf einmal doch sehr
massiv sagt wir müssen mit Waffen rein
vorher hieß es noch erinnern Sie sich
bärbock hat Harbeck zurückgepfiffen im
Wahlkampf als Harbeck gesagt hat wir
werden nicht umhin kommen das war noch
vor Beginn des Krieges
Verteidigungswaffen an die Ukraine zu
liefern da sagte Berber kommt auf keinen
Fall in Frage ja gut und jetzt überlege
ich mir manchmal das ist eine längere
Geschichte ich war am Anfang auch ein
bisschen irritiert über diese dieses
Phänomen das so viele die vorher ganz in
meinen Augen ganz zu Unrecht übrigens
der Meinung war unter keinen Bedingungen
die Kurden Hofreiter dürfen nicht
unterstützt werden die Kurden die
einzigen halbwegs vernünftigen in dem
Syrien Konflikt dürfen nicht unterstützt
werden mit Waffen und so weiter und so
weiter dass dieselben auf einmal so um
switchen in ihrer Orientierung und das
hat mich beschäftigt da könnten das
länger drüber reden und eine Erklärung
scheint mir folgende zu sein
auch gar keine Kritik was ganz normal
wir wachsen in bestimmten Zeiten auf wer
nach 1990 darunter ist hier niemand ja
auch nicht siehe naja jünger sind als
ich werden erst nach 1990 politisch
sozialisiert wurde
hatte eine Welt vor sich bei der
jedenfalls den Eindruck hatte der Westen
der kann die Dinge in Ordnung bringen es
gab auch massive Unterstützung für
sogenannte humanitäre Interventionen und
so weiter der Westen kann doch wenn er
will
und die Älteren die haben noch in
Erinnerung als Kind Kubakrise wie meine
Eltern dann auf einmal Reis gekauft
haben oder dann 83 noch mal beinahe
dritter Weltkrieg da steckt uns
gewissermaßen in den Knochen und auch
die Versuche mit einer stalinistischen
üblen Diktatur spätzstalistisch dann in
irgendeiner Weise zu einem Ausgleich zu
kommen und die sagen sich moment mal
jetzt dürfen wir nicht auf einmal
leichtsinnig werden und ich setze hinzu
vielleicht ein bisschen realistischer
das Spiel ist aus der Westen hatte die
Chance viel zu gestalten die New World
Order von Busch Senior war nicht so
völlig absurd nach 1990 das wird der
frühere Außenminister vielleicht
bestätigen ja der das wurde der letzten
frei gewählten DDR Regierung unter
lothara
so neudeutsch heißt das wurde im Grunde
nicht genutzt mit zum Teil absurden
Interventionen die alle schief gegangen
sind Afghanistan und so weiter Moment
und jetzt ist die Vorstellung die ja
jetzt haben wir hier in der Ukraine
natürlich einen Kriegs ist in der Tat
vor der Haustür das kann auf keinen Fall
sein übrigens will nur mal festhalten
wir waren uns alle einig dass die
Ukraine unterstützt werden muss damit
sie sich verteidigen kann Greifer waren
wir hier diese auch mal schön eine
Einigkeit festzustellen Frage ist nur
wie geht's jetzt weiter
und ich glaube wir müssen lernen dass
wir eine extrem instabile Weltlage haben
dass wir drei Weltmächte haben mit der
einen Weltmacht verbinde ganz viel mit
der USA Demokratie transatlantisches
Bündnis Menschenrechte aber alle drei
Weltmächte sind unzufrieden mit dem
Status Quo gewesen in den letzten
Jahrzehnten sie haben Chancen genutzt
das zu verändern der spätankömmling
china macht das ganz massiv mit massiver
Aufrüstung gegenwärtig Russland reagiert
mit einem regionalen Imperialismus
sozusagen in seiner Region mit
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskriegen das
ist hoch gefährlich ja und in dieser
Situation erinnert man sich
gewissermaßen an die mühsamen Schritte
die dazu geführt haben dass wir so viele
Jahrzehnte nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
eine Friedenszeit hatten und über die
Schritte raus über mögliche Schritte
raus aus diesem Konflikt über unseren
Plan hier an diesem Tisch für diesen
Krieg raus aus diesem Krieg sprechen wir
gleich nach einer ganz kurz
[Musik]
wir kommen zurück bei Bild bei den
richtigen Fragen wir suchen nach unserem
Plan in diesem Krieg nach einem Jahr
Krieg und wir tun das unterem unter
anderem mit Bischof Christian Stäblein
von der evangelischen Kirche hier in
Berlin Brandenburg ein Jahr Krieg und
die Frage wie wir daraus kommen haben
sie für sich eine Idee wo wir ja in
sechs in zwölf Monaten stehen und wie
wir dahin kommen hoffentlich mit einem
Ende dieses Krieges das muss glaube ich
ganz vorne stehen allerdings so wir
haben ja hier schon einiges am Tisch
gehört dass wir eine Ukraine haben die
frei und selbstbestimmt über ihre
Zukunft reden kann und das auch in den
Grenzen die zu ihr gehören und nicht in
verschobenen Grenzen das glaube ich muss
das Ziel sein das zweite was hier schon
zur Sprache gekommen ist ist die Frage
mit welchen Partnern kann man überhaupt
verhandeln an dieser Stelle das wird
eine große Herausforderung sein und das
was mich immer besonders dann noch mal
herausfordert das sind die vielen
begleitenden zivilen Partnerschaften und
Lösungen die wir brauchen wir sind jetzt
mitten in einer ganz furchtbaren
Situation aber unser Blick muss immer
darüber hinausgehen damit wir die
Völkerverständigung die Partnerschaften
das Reden mit der russischen Opposition
so wie wir es jetzt ja gerade auch aus
München erlebt haben dass wir das stark
machen denn am Ende darf es ja nicht zu
einer Situation kommen in der ein
dauerhafter Konflikt zwischen den
Völkern existiert sondern in der wir
eine friedensituation schaffen in der
neu und selbstbestimmt gestaltet werden
verfügst sie alles allen in allen
entscheidenden Frage bleibt wie zwingt
man wie kann man Putin in eine Situation
zwingen in der er gemütigt ist an den
Verhandlungstisch zu gehen denn im
Moment will er das ja nicht lehnt es ab
mit Maximalforderung das heißt muss man
viel mehr aus ihrer Sicht mehr töten ihn
viel mehr Schwächen damit er dazu bereit
ist wenn man die
Historikerinnen und
Politikwissenschaftlerin eine Apple Baum
zitieren die sich sehr
intensiv mit osteuropäischer Geschichte
mit Russland mit Mittelosteuropa
beschäftigt hat und auch diesen Krieg
sehr intensiv begleitet intellektuell
die sagte dieser Krieg wird erst
aufhören wenn die russischen Machteliten
zu dem Schluss kommen dass es ein
fataler Fehler war
und an diesem Punkt werden Sie
vermutlich erst kommen wenn sie mit
einer Niederlage konfrontiert sind ich
glaube wir müssen uns
zur hart das klingt darauf einstellen
dass mit putinen kein nachhaltiger
Frieden mögliches Putin hat im Grunde
den Rubicon überschritten hinter dem er
nicht mehr zurück kann er geht aufs
Ganze und das ist eine Situation vor der
wir psychologisch zurückschäumen dass
man mit einem Gegner konfrontiert wird
er ist mit dem ist kein Kompromiss gibt
sondern nur die Frage wer sich gegen wen
durchsetzt sie sagen uns sie haben das
ja auch in diesen Stunden getwittert
genau diese Antwort von Apple Baum die
eben sagt ja die Eliten in Russland die
müssen einsehen dass es sich nicht lohnt
diesen Krieg zu führen und sie sagen
obendrein sie werden das erst dann
einsehen wenn eine Niederlage droht was
ist die Niederlage eine Atom macht
wir haben ja Beispiele die Amerikaner
mussten sich aus Vietnam zurückziehen
aus Afghanistan aus dem Irak
die Sowjetunion musste sich auch aus
Afghanistan zurückziehen nach einem
blutigen Krieg also man kann nichts
sagen eine Atommacht kann keinen Krieg
auf fremden Territorium verlieren darum
geht es ja niemand sagt wir müssen
Russland auf dem eigenen Territorium
besiegen wir müssen Krieg gegen Russland
führen sondern Russland muss scheitern
militärisch in der Ukraine damit es
überhaupt eine Chance gibt aus diesem
imperialen waren
aufzuwachen weil es braucht den Schutz
einer russischen Niederlage damit
Russland den Abschied vom Imperium
findet dies würde einen zermürbenden
Krieg voraussetzen ein womöglich
jahrelang wenn ich jahrzehntelang Kriege
sind doch nicht unbegrenzt die haben
heute schon enorme Nachschub Probleme
eine entscheidende Frage wird es sein ob
China sagen liefert der Iran alleine
wird diesen Krieg nicht für Russland
mitentscheiden können so wenn der Westen
sein Ressourcen in die Waagschale wirft
wir sind Russland so unendliche
ökonomisch überlegen wir haben so viel
mehr Reserven Russland ist isoliert
international in dieser Maschine die
nicht die Produktion nicht genau die
Munition der Munition ist Leute in
Russland derzeit deutlich schneller als
innerhalb der europäischen Schichten in
ihren Rüstungsbetrieben bei uns wird
immer noch ein Schichtbetrieb gefahren
ich glaube wir brauchen diese
Entschlossenheit dass wir
die Ukraine so weit unterstützen müssen
das Russland zumindest an den Rand einer
Niederlage gebracht wird erst das
ermöglicht Verhandlungen zu akzeptablen
Konditionen in der hat sich das für eine
realistische Szenario ein denkbares
Szenario das die russische Führung
irgendwann sagt das ist so zermögen für
uns wie Afghanistan damals nach sehr
sehr vielen Jahren wir ziehen uns zurück
also man weiß nie wie die Dinge weiter
sich entwickeln Prognosen sind extrem
schwierig
wir waren vorher uns einig wir sind hier
alle keine Militärexperten und ich würde
sagen da sollte man mal dabei bleiben
ich halte das für eine gefährliche
Illusion das wird sich erst im
Nachhinein herausstellen vielleicht noch
weiteren 100.000 und von Toten wer jetzt
dieses Szenario für als realistisch
ausgibt und sagt jetzt müssen wir
entsprechend agieren also natürlich dann
mit Kampfjets und U-Booten und Marine
und vielleicht noch mit Nuklearwaffen
der weckt eine ganz gefährliche Illusion
beiden hat Polen vor Monaten untersagt
Kampfjets an die Ukraine zu liefern die
USA war sehr zurückhaltend mit erbrems
und hat das jetzt nur akzeptiert nachdem
da noch ein zeitlicher
verzögerungsfaktor mit drin ist
in der amerikanischen Bevölkerung gibt
es massive Widerstände gegen weitere
große Ausgaben das ist jetzt meine
Einschätzung sie können ja ihre
Einschätzung haben diese Vorstellung des
totalen umfassenden Sieges bei dem der
letzte russische Soldat von ukrainischen
Territorium einschließlich der Krim
hinaus gedrängt wird oder getötet wird
das weckt genau diese Erwartungen
nämlich der Ukraine jetzt zu sagen so
jetzt seid Ihr aber dran das kann dazu
führen dass am Ende doch noch das
passiert was alle verantwortlichen
Politiker gegenwärtig zu vermeiden
suchen nämlich dass die NATO oder
NATO-Staaten und damit auch die NATO
Kriegspartei wird sie haben China so
abgetan ich meine China einerseits macht
den ambivalente Außenpolitik gegenwärtig
und wer man muss ein bisschen unter die
Oberfläche schauen nicht nur immer das
was gesagt wird so überlegen was steckt
der möglicherweise dahinter china will
dass der Krieg aufhört weil das stört
ihre Geschäfte das wäre das macht aus
dem die Taiwan Sache so wichtig das
glaube ich gerne zu gleichen Zeit will
China natürlich auf keinen Fall das
Russland total Niederlage erleidet das
heißt wir wissen überhaupt nicht wie
eine solche eskalationszynamik am Ende
aussieht und deswegen waren nicht davor
sich darauf einzugehen sie beschäftigen
sich in ihrem aktuellen in ihrem neuen
Buch genau mit diesen Perspektiven hin
zu einem Ausweg aus diesem Krieg wir
sehen hier noch einmal den Titel
stehen bleiben ich wollte gerade ganz
bewusst an diesen Punkt wenn wir darüber
reden
Putin an einen Punkt zu bringen an dem
man möglicherweise bereit ist an den
Verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren bedeutet das dass wir
noch brutaler noch mehr töten müssen um
ihn da reinzuzwingen ist dass die
Wahrheit nein das sind keine Sätze den
ich mich anschließen kann wir müssen die
Ukraine es klingt so schrecklich aber
das ist die Wahrheit nein wir müssen
keine weiteren befähigen sich beleidigen
zu können gegenüber diesem Aggressor und
wir müssen sie weiter darin stärken so
durchzuhalten dass wir einen Frieden
tatsächlich schaffen können aber das
heißt für mich ich muss es jetzt doch an
dieser Stelle einmal sagen beten und
Handeln und das heißt auch an dieser
Stelle für mich immer wieder um Frieden
und um ein Schweigen der Waffen beten
können und gleichzeitig die Ukraine so
stärken dass sie in dieser Situation für
ihre Freiheit und für einen gerechten
Frieden eintreten kann aber wir müssen
beides zusammen denken ich kriege das
nicht spannungslos hin und sie kriegen
mich zu einer spannungslosen Antworten
ich möchte noch einmal zu der Frage weil
natürlich wenn wir hier in Deutschland
über Solidarität sprechen und unsere
Pläne ausbreiten dann wird dem einen
oder anderen oder möglicherweise auch
100000 in der Ukraine die hutschen
hochgehen die nämlich an der Front
kämpfen müssen und bedeutet genau das
nämlich am Ende wenn wir darüber reden
dass Putin an den verhand praktisch zu
rollt gerade eben doch mehr töten
es ist Licht unsere Aufgabe dieses zu
entscheiden hier gibt es das ein
überfallenes Volk
und letztlich muss dort die Entscheidung
fällen wie lange man sich verteidigen
will mit welchem Blut soll das ist
nichts was wir entscheiden können und
über die Ukraine hinweg hier klare
Aussagen zu machen denke ich sollte wir
sehr ruhig sein und sollten dieses eben
nicht tun Richtung putin ist das ganz
klar meine das ist doch die Aufgabe zu
sagen die Aggression muss scheitern das
heißt ja die Aggressionen Bescheid dann
und das kann nicht sein dass diese
Aggression erfolgreich ist dafür sollten
wir einen treten und das ist unsere
Verantwortung die Ukraine zu stärken
dieses zu erreichen was Sie erreichen
will
übrigens
hat auch eine abstrimension sondern hat
auch eine abschränkungsdimension die
dann
passieren aber die konventionellen kommt
der Ukraine früher Luftabwehr geliefert
oder die Panzer von heute wäre dieser
Krieg vielleicht schon zu Ende
von der Zivilbevölkerung wären deutlich
geringer ich denke das ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe ist dieses Ende zu bestimmen
dieses muss am Ende in der Ukraine
gemacht werden und dann kommt die
Entschuldigung dann kommt diese kommt
diese Frage mit nach Putin wenn alle die
erst noch Verhandlungen rufen muss man
ja fragen was glaubt man in
Verhandlungen mit Putin erreichen Putin
hat alles gebrochen was er bisher
unterschrieben hat alles übrigens auch
schon mal die Souveränität der Ukraine
zu schützen in dem Budapester marmorant
und 1994 all das ist nicht dass die
Tinte Wert unter der gesetzt hat und
dann müssen wir das muss ich mal sagen
wer Verhandlungen jetzt ruft muss ich
darüber Gedanken machen wer das
Verhandlungsergebnis das nicht wir
bestimmt sondern dass die Ukraine
zentral bestimmt wer dieses sichert und
da sage ich müssen wir zur Verfügung
stehen wir auch als Deutscher als NATO
zur Verfügung stehen diese
Sicherheitsgarantien mit abzugeben und
das heißt dann aber wiederum wenn die
gebrochen werden sind wir dann wirklich
Teil der Auseinandersetzung das heißt
diese Dimension müssen wir jetzt auch an
dieser Stelle schon mitdenken und das
tut glaube ich viele nicht die
sachverhandlungen rufen weil so komplex
das Thema ist wir haben noch eine knappe
Minute sie waren im Kanzleramt wenn sie
dort aktuell werden sie waren dort in
anderer Rolle sie müssten sich im Moment
um Außenpolitik kümmern was wäre ihr
Ratschlag um rauszukommen um an den
Verhandlungstisch zu kommen also ich
habe die Beratungen im Vorfeld des
Irakkrieges ist zweiten amerikanischen
Irakkrieges durchaus zum Teil miterlebt
weil ich damit eingeladen war diesen
Abend unten und weiß deswegen auch wie
sehr da so zwei Ebenen sind ja was so
geredet wird und was nun die
Auseinandersetzung mit den Detailfragen
ist ja meine Empfehlung wäre dreiteilig
das zumindest ernsthaft zu versuchen
erstens Rückzug Russlands auf die
Grenzen von 24 Februar des letzten Jahr
Russland nicht lehnt Russland ist alle
lehnen im Augenblick alles ab das ist
immer so bei solchen Situationen man
schaue in die Geschichte alle gehen mit
Maximalforderungen rein und am Ende
kommt ein Kompromiss raus Russland war
ja offenbar dazu schon mal bereit wenn
uns nicht der Ministerpräsident Israels
der vormalige belügt das hat er doch den
Wahlen ja immentiert wirklich sie kommen
sie halt weil die die Artikel und die
öffentlich klären es gibt diese eine
Minute gegeben das diese möglicherweise
Legende der kriminell gerne nach keine
Legende das kann nicht sein vorhin
erfährt hat das sehr sehr seriöse
Zeitschriften das wirst du bestätigen
hat das ebenfalls geschrieben egal
Russland muss ich zurückziehen zweiter
Punkt
lasst in den Separatisten Gebieten auf
der Krim die Bevölkerung entscheiden und
der Ägide der Vereinten Nationen dritter
Punkt zwei Möglichkeiten entweder eine
stabile Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa
die auf Dauer auch die Ukraine und
andere Länder in der Umgebung Russlands
schützt oder
NATO-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine bei
Berücksichtigung der
Sicherheitsinteressen auch Russlands was
Finnland und Schweden zum Beispiel mit
dem NATO-Beitritt auch gegenwärtig
verbinden und sagen was das genau heißt
für waffenstationierung das müssen wir
noch klären das würde ich wenn sie mich
schon fragen dem Bundeskanzler oder der
Bundeskanzlerin vorschlagen zu schauen
ob Frankreich ob andere Länder Brasilien
insbesondere die USA dieses im Westen
mitgehen und ganz auszuloten ob es eine
Bereitschaft gibt und ich gebe ihnen
völlig recht wir wissen es nicht ob
Russland sich darauf einlässt und das
liegt auch daran dass wir nicht wissen
wie die Ukraine gestützt werden muss
damit Russland sich nicht der Illusion
gibt seine alten Kriegsziele reg change
und so weiter zu erreichen das ist ihr
Plan für einen Weg aus dem Krieg raus
wir haben diskutiert heute Abend über
unseren Plan raus aus diesem Krieg nach
einem Jahr kriege ich danke Ihnen
herzlich Bischof Stäblein in
niederrümelin herr Fuchs und Herr Merkel
und wir sind nächste Woche zurück hier
bei Bild die richtigen Fragen bis dahin
mit dem letzten Punkt stimmen wir völlig
[Musik]